un último cambio en las recomendaciones
sobre las vacunas contra el coronavirus
los receptores de la primera dosis de
astrazéneca seguirán recibiendo su
segunda dosis a tiempo pero de un
fabricante diferente lo que significa
que más de 500 personas en francia
tendrán una mezcla de dos vacunas
diferentes el ministro de sanidad
francés que recibió la de astrazéneca en
febrero habló el viernes en la radio
francesa para tranquilizar al público
bill es totalmente coherente decir que
no recomendamos la vacuna de los menores
de 55 años esto es provisional hasta que
sepamos más es una medida de precaución
así que si has recibido tu primera
inyección de astrazéneca y tienes menos
de 55 años te daremos una vacuna
diferente eso me incluye a dieta sin
certificación la organización mundial de
la salud recomienda que se utilice el
mismo producto de ambas dosis y advierte
que es necesario seguir investigando
sobre el uso conjunto de diferentes
vacunas especialmente porque el suero de
oxford es una vacuna tradicional que
expone al paciente a una forma débil del
virus mientras que moderna y facer
variante que utilizan a rn mensajero un
nuevo enfoque de las vacunas sin embargo
los expertos afirman que este enfoque
esto no es motivo de alarma
no nos preocupan las posibles alergias y
tampoco nos preocupa la eficacia aunque
aún no se haya demostrado en humanos
pero tenemos suficiente información de
otras vacunas y animales que demuestran
que funcionarán donde el inland pulmón
hayes abre tiritas según una encuesta
reciente el 71% del público francés
notoriamente escéptico a las vacunas ya
no confía en la vacuna de oxford 10
millones de personas en francia han
recibido al menos una dosis de la vacuna
contra el coronavirus incluyendo a casi
todos los adultos mayores de las casas
de retiro